HELLO AGAIN FROM FOX NEWS IN
WASHINGTON.
IT HAS BEEN A BUSY WEEK ON THE
CONTINUING EFFORT TO GAIN MORE
CONTROL OVER THE COVID PANDEMIC.
FDA ADVISORY PANEL RECOMMENDED
BOOSTERS FOR TWO OR MORE
VACCINES FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
THEY WILL CONSIDER WHETHER IT
SAFE FOR PEOPLE TO MIX OR MATCH
TO GET INITIAL DOSES OF ONE
VACCINE AND THE BOOSTERS OF
ANOTHER.
THE BATTLE OF HER VACCINE
MANDATES.
WHETHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE BUSINESSES CAN ORDER
PEOPLE TO GET SHOTS CONTINUED TO
ESCALATE.
SOME ESSENTIAL WORKERS MAY STAY
OFF OF THE JOB RATHER THAN
COMPLY WITH MANDATES.
WE WANT TO DISCUSS ALL OF THIS,
PLUS GET THE LATEST ON THIS PART
OF THE VIRUS, FROM DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
MEDICAL ADVISOR.
WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY"."
>> Dr. Fauci: THANK YOU,
CHRIS.
IT’S GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Chris: THE FDA ADVISORY
PANEL THIS WEEK RECOMMENDED
APPLICATION FOR THE USE OF THE
TWO OTHER BOOSTERS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN APPROVED SO FAR, MODERNA
AND J&J EVEN THOUGH THE DATA ON
J&J BOOSTERS WAS PRETTY WEAK
ACCORDING TO SOME OF THE
SCIENTISTS ON THAT PANEL.
HAS THE POLITICS OF GIVING
BOOSTERS COTTON AHEAD OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH?
>> Dr. Fauci: I’M NOT SO SURE
THAT THE POLITICS GOT AHEAD OF
IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA THAT HAS
BEEN ACCUMULATED NOT ONLY FROM
OUR COHORTS THAT WE FILING HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, BUT THE
INFORMATION WHICH IS CRITICAL
INFORMATION WE ARE GETTING FROM
ISRAEL, IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT
THERE IS WANING IMMUNITY AND
THAT WE DO NEED TO BOOST
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE RECEIVED
ANY OF THE THREE PRODUCTS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH RIGHT
NOW.
AS YOU MENTIONED, JUST THIS PAST
WEEK, TWO OF THEM, MODERNA AND
J&J, BUT THERE DATA BEFORE THE
FDA AND THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MADE AN A RECOMMENDATION.
THERE WILL NOT BE A POLITICAL
ISSUE THERE AND IT’S JUST PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA AND EVIDENCE.
>> Chris: THE FDA PANEL WILL
NOW ALSO CONSIDER WHETHER IT IS
SAFE TO MIX AND MATCH TO GET
YOUR INITIAL DOSE FROM ONE
VACCINE AND THEN YOUR BOOSTER
FROM ANOTHER VACCINE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY AN ISSUE WITH
J&J WHICH, ACCORDING TO THE
DATA, HAS -- OFFERS LESS
PRODUCTION.
TO THINK THAT MIX-AND-MATCH IS
SAFE AND SHOULDN’T PEOPLE WHO
GOT J&J VACCINE INITIALLY
CONSIDER GETTING A BOOSTER
FROM ANOTHER VACCINE THAT
OFFERS MORE PROTECTION?
>> Dr. Fauci: WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE, AND I BELIEVE WILL BE
DONE, IS THAT THERE WILL BE A
DEGREE OF FLEXIBILITY THAT WILL
BE LEFT UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL
BASED ON THEIR INDIVIDUAL
SITUATION.
THE POINT THAT YOU MAKE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA FROM J&J
THAT WAS PRESENTED TO THE FDA
WHEN THEY USE THEIR OWN PRODUCT
AS A BOOST, IT IS BASED ON
CLINICAL DATA FROM A
CLINICAL TRIAL.
THE MIX AND MATCH TO WHICH SHOWS
THAT WHEN YOU BOOST MADERA OR
PFIZER AGAINST THE ORIGINAL
J&J, YOU GET A MUCH HIGHER
ANTIBODY LEVEL.
IT IS A LABORATORY DATA.
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
J&J AGAINST J&J FROM TRIAL AND
THE DATA THEY PRESENTED IS BASED
ON CLINICAL DATA.
WHAT YOU’RE GOING TO SEE WITHOUT
A DOUBT IS THAT THE FDA’S GOING
TO TAKE ALL OF THAT UNDER
ADVISEMENT AND MAKE A REGULATORY
GET TO THE CDC WITH THEIR
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THEY WILL MAKE A RECOMMENDATION
AND I BELIEVE THERE’S GOING TO
BE A DEGREE OF FLEXIBILITY FOR
SOMEONE WHO GOT J&J ORIGINALLY
COME OVER THEY CAN DO.
EITHER WITH J&J OR WITH THE
MIX-AND-MATCH FROM OTHER
PRODUCTS.
>> Chris: LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT
WHERE WE ARE IN THIS FOURTH WAVE
OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
THERE’S AN AVERAGE OF ALMOST
84,000 NEW CASES EVERY DAY AND
MORE THAN 1500 DEATHS EVERY DAY.
STILL BAD, BUT DOWN CONSIDERABLY
FROM A MONTH AGO.
ARE WE COMING OUT OF THE DELTA
WAVE?
AS WE HEADED INTO COLDER
WEATHER, PEOPLE GOING INSIDE,
HOLIDAY TRAVEL, WHAT IS THE REAL
POSSIBILITY THAT WE COULD HAVE A
FIFTH WEIGHT OF THE VIRUS?
ESPECIALLY, IF THERE ISN’T A
SPIKE IN THE VACCINATIONS?
>> Dr. Fauci: THAT’S FOR THE
PROBLEM COME AT YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
IT’S GOING TO BE WITHIN HER
CAPABILITY.
YOU’RE RIGHT.
CASES ARE DOWN 23% OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS ARE
DOWN 17 OR 18%.
WE ALL HAVE APPROXIMATELY
66 MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE VACCINATED THAT
ARE NOT VACCINATED.
THE DEGREE TO WHICH WE CONTINUE
TO COME DOWN IN THAT SLOPE WILL
DEPEND ON HOW WHAT WE DO ON IT
GETTING MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
IF WE DO NOT DO VERY WELL IN
THAT REGARD, THERE’S ALWAYS THE
DANGER THAT THERE WILL BE ENOUGH
CIRCULATING VIRUS THAT YOU CAN
HAVE A STALLING OF THE
DIMINISHING OF THE NUMBER OF
CASES.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, AS WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE PAST WITH OTHER
WAVES THAT WE’VE BEEN THROUGH,
THERE’S THE DANGER OF
RESURGENCE.
WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT THAT WE
KEEP EMPHASIZING.
MORE PEOPLE WE GET VACCINATED,
THE LESS LIKELIHOOD THERE IS
THAT THERE’S GOING TO BE ANOTHER
SEARCH AS WE GO TO THE WINTER.
>> Chris: BRIEFLY, WHAT IS
YOUR ADVICE FOR THE HOLIDAY
SEASON QUESTION REQ FOR TRAVEL,
GATHER TOGETHER AS FAMILIES?
FOR GROUPS THAT ARE VACCINATED
AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT?
>> Dr. Fauci: FOR GROUPS THAT
ARE VACCINATED, WE CAN ENJOY THE
HOLIDAY SEASON.
I GUESS THAT ALL THE TIME.
TRICK-OR-TREATING ON HALLOWEEN,
THANKSGIVING WITH THE FAMILY.
WHEN YOU’RE IN THE FAMILY UNIT
AMONG PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED,
YOU SHOULD ENJOY THE HOLIDAYS AS
BEST YOU CAN IN THE FAMILY
SPIRIT.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED, FIRST, I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THEM VERY STRONGLY TO
GET VACCINATED.
IF THEY ARE NOT, DO WITH THE CDC
RECOMMENDS.
WHEN YOU ARE IN AN INDOOR
SETTING, PUBLIC INDOOR SETTING,
WHERE MASK WE KNOW THAT MASKS WO
LIKELIHOOD THAT YOU’RE GOING TO
GET INFECTED.
THAT’S WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT TO
GET VACCINATED.
NOT ONLY WILL IT BE GOOD FOR
YOUR OWN HEALTH AND THAT OF YOUR
FAMILY, IT WILL MAKE IT MUCH
EASIER FOR YOU TO ENJOY THE
KINDS OF THINGS IN SOCIETY AT
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO ENJOY
ANYWAY.
>> Chris: LET ME PICK UP ON
THAT, DOCTOR.
TEXAS GOVERNOR, GREG ABBOTT,
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
BANNING ANY ANTEDATE BE A PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE, MIXED DATING THE
PEOPLE GET VACCINES.
HERE HE WAS LAST JUNE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TEXAS IS OPEN 100%.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE THE FREEDOM TO GO WHERE YOU
WANT WITHOUT LIMITS.
>> Chris: WHAT YOU THINK OF
GOVERNOR ABBOTT?
>> Dr. Fauci: I’M NOT GOING TO
MAKE ANYTHING ABOUT MY PERSONAL
OPINION OTHER THAN TO SAY FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT, THAT
IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
WE KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE VACCINES
ARE IN PREVENTING NOT ONLY
ILLNESS FOR THE INDIVIDUAL, BUT
FOR THE DEMENTED STOMACH
DIMINISHING THE EFFECTS IN
SOCIETY.
THE DATA IS CLEAR.
IT DOES NOT MATTER WHAT I THINK
OR DON’T THINK OF
GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
LOOK AT THE DATA AND LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO
ARE VACCINATED AND PEOPLE WHO
WERE UNVACCINATED.
IN CASES, HOSPITALIZATIONS, AND
IN DEATHS.
THE CDC CAME OUT WITH RECENT
DATA AND THE DATA IS REALLY
STRIKING.
THE RISK OF BEING VACCINATED
VERSUS THE PROTECTION YOU GET
WHEN VACCINATED.
GO AHEAD.
>> Chris: NO, GO AHEAD.
FINISH HER SENTENCE.
>> Dr. Fauci: UNFORTUNATELY, I
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT THE GOVERNOR
IS TRYING TO DO, BUT WHEN YOU’RE
IN A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS,
SOMETIMES UNUSUAL SITUATIONS
REQUIRE UNUSUAL ACTIONS.
IN THIS CASE, IT IS THINGS LIKE
MANDATED INK.
BE THEY VACCINATIONS.
THEY ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
WERE NOT YET LIVING IN A VACUUM
AS INDIVIDUALS.
WERE LIVING IN SOCIETY.
SOCIETY NEEDS TO DO TO BE
PROTECTED AND YOU DO THAT BY
PROTECTING OTHER PEOPLE AROUND
YOU BY GETTING VACCINATED.
>> Chris: I WOULD LIKE TO
SQUEEZE INTO MORE QUESTIONS.
IN A NUMBER OF QUESTION PLACES,
POLICE, PILOTS, HEALTH WORKERS,
THREATENING.
ARE LIKELY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
POLICE UNION IN CHICAGO IN THE
MIRROR THAT CITY.
HERE THEY ARE.
>> IT IS SAFE TO SAY THAT THE
CITY OF CHICAGO WILL HAVE A
FORCE OF 50% OR LEFT COMING UP.
>> IF THOSE WHO ARE SWORN TO
UPHOLD THE LAW ACTED AS THOUGH
THEY ARE ABOVE THE LAW.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TOLERATE
THAT.
THAT’S UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Chris: WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ESSENTIAL WORKERS GOING
OFF THE JOB, LIKE HAVE A POLICE
FORCE, SHOULD LOCAL AND
CORPORATE EXECUTIVES BACK OFF
ENFORCING THESE MANDATES?
>> Dr. Fauci: I AM NOT
COMFORTABLE TELLING PEOPLE WHAT
THEY SHOULD DO ON THE NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT WE ARE NOT A
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT NOW.
TAKE THE POLICE.
WE KNOW NOW THAT THE STATISTICS,
MORE POLICE OFFICERS DIVE COVID
AND THEY DO HAVE OTHER CAUSES
OF DEATH.
IT DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE IF
YOU ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AS WELL AS THE
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU WORK WITH.
IF WE COULD GET PEOPLE TO THINK
ON THAT.
THINK OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF NOT
GETTING VACCINATED WHEN YOU’RE
IN A POSITION WHERE YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBLE JOB AND YOU WANT TO
PROTECT YOURSELF BECAUSE YOU ARE
NEEDED AT YOUR JOB.
WHETHER YOU ARE A POLICE OFFICER
OR A PILOT OR ANY OTHER OF THOSE
KINDS OF OCCUPATIONS.
>> Chris: FINALLY, WHEN THIS
PANDEMIC STARTED, IT IS FAIR TO
SAY YOU WERE GENERALLY REGARDED
AS THE AUTHORITY ON INFECTIOUS
DISEASE.
AS TIME HAS GONE ON, YOU HAVE
BECOME A POLARIZING FIGURE AND
CRITICS ACCUSE YOU OF SENDING
MIXED MESSAGES, THERE’S
ALLEGATIONS THAT YOU HELPED FUND
DANGEROUS RESEARCH AT THE WUHAN
LAB.
TWO QUESTIONS.
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE BECOME
SO CONTROVERSIAL COURSEWORK
HONESTLY, DO YOU THINK THERE’S
ANYTHING YOU HAVE DONE THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO THAT?
SPEECH ARE NOT SURE I COULD
ANSWER THE LATTER BECAUSE I CAN
THINK OF ANYTHING.
I’M SURE SOME PEOPLE WILL.
I HAVE ALWAYS STOOD FOR MAKING
SCIENCE, DATA, AND EVIDENCE BE
WHAT WE GUIDE OURSELVES BY.
PEOPLE THAT FEEL DIFFERENTLY AND
TO HAVE CONSPIRACY SERIES AND
DENY REALITY LOOKING HIM
STRAIGHT IN THE EYE IT, THOSE
ARE PEOPLE THAT DO NOT
PARTICULARLY CARE FOR ME.
AND THAT’S UNDERSTANDABLE.
I TRY VERY HARD TO BE GUIDED BY
THE TRUTH AND IT SOMETIMES THE
TRUTH BECOMES INCONVENIENT FOR
SOME PEOPLE.
THEN THEY REACT AGAINST ME.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THERE’S NOT MUCH I CAN DO ABOUT
THAT.
>> Chris: DR. FAUCI,
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS